in a video I saw online Carol Baskin
who's also another you know she's
another cat owner and farmer that's
featured in the in the documentary Carol
Carol really pushes the envelope of you
guys miss handling cub treatment over
there right and some some crazy illusion
of it you know the cub is a super
valuable character that is why it
because why's the cups are valuable he
create like why is all why is it all
about the Cubs like everyone's always
like the Cubs the Cubs the Cubs why is
that the real reason is it's just they
know it's gonna hit the heartstrings of
people so they want to create drama
unfounded unprecedented endless drama
people like peril and PETA just trying
to make up a story of course the Cubs
are super valuable to us as individuals
as characters that hold vital genetics
to our ongoing program almost forty
years where we've been holding these
family of tigers together have known
several hundred Tigers in that time
trying to add them hold up that genetics
which may in fact save the tiger and
Andrew that may be that there will even
be Tigers on the planet and time to come
a baby tiger needs TLC around the clock
you just can't rough them and handle
them in some way that's inappropriate
they are cared for round-the-clock
handled super minimally you know they
pretend like we're passing them off in a
line twenty minutes people come they get
a 20-minute interaction three days a
week that's it one hour whatever and
what about when they age out of kind of
that sugar realm where people are loving
them and you know like they start to
become you know hit the terrible twos
you know like even like children do do
you guys is there is there an
underground railroad or something where
you guys get rid of Tigers at that point
or is there you know what's the real
deal you see all those those guys that
are with Cody those are Cody's uh you
know brothers and sisters that he's out
there with all day he's got every color
every size every shape boys girls we
continually have a relationship with
those guys throughout their life
cradle-to-grave they're important
characters than on the preserve we swim
with them in a huge pool they're gonna
be great big guys for that we have a big
tiger run where we have a tiger
chase I speed Lords we have ten Tigers
that are set up to go and chase that
lure system and be part of the whole
interactive part of the tour and big
Tigers come out twenty two adults are on
our big night Safari dinner party every
Tiger has a vital importance to us and
is like critical characters plus this
idea that someone would do that taking a
tiger and killing it taking a tiger and
getting rid of I wouldn't do it it's a
crime and do it unless the tiger attack
me or something I probably wouldn't do
it no it's immoral it's it's it's a no
purpose to it and it's not going to be
something that creates a benefit of
business you need this Tiger to be there
for his genetics or his beauty for what
he's going to be able to do later and as
an individual he's a highly important
loving caring character but a girl a boy
sat there holding and loving and giving
it a bottle around the clock and always
being with it so these are our imprinted
fur children in their own way as these
are family members you know and we have
the world's oldest cat was here the
world's oldest bear was here there are
so really retirees here that are decades
old and we called them along so they
cross the rain is Joe Biden there I feel
like Joe Biden should be in there as
well kind of I wouldn't be surprised if
he qualifies in that group maybe so yeah
obviously if you guys were doing
anything harmful to animals it would
really harm your business but why do
other why is there such venom between
different cat camps where they're like
they're doing this they're doing this
why why isn't there more of a unified
group that we're all doing the right
thing do you feel like there's a couple
reasons one those guys are out there
running a gigantic fund raising business
to get people to send them money to
rescue something in need so they have to
create drama you have to say these
animals need our help today you give us
a dollar
we'll help make this change whether the
change is real or not has nothing to do
with the equation that's right
guys who are pretending to be rescue you
look at my place at shangri-la huge open
forest habitats beautiful waterfalls and
ponds and space everywhere beautiful
I've seen the video online yes somebody
else videos online man it is really it
is beautiful I feel like I went to like
one of the covers on remember the job is
witness they give you that cover of the
fan flip
well paranoid it would have a yeah yeah
beautiful know that and you look at
Carol's place holy out a dungeon is so
Lopes like white slavery over there to
it is a very white slavery kind of odd
she's making four to five million
dollars a year according to her taxes
but it's all donation is that right
what's that but her money is they
they're able to earn money through
donation right that and the other camps
don't do that is that correct right it's
a totally separate thing
how praise that money and what they're
doing with it you know I mean you got
the activists that are like PETA or a
Humane Society United States who are a
vegan world order do they want everybody
to be forced vegetarian and want every
human animal interaction to stop and
they will they say that all zoos are bad
and of course you can't ride a horse you
certainly can't go get a puppy as a
matter of you see a pound every animals
better off dead the head of PETA has
said that no world without puppies would
be just fine me and with me my entire
life and I think it's essential to get
that love and understanding in
connection to ourselves and animals to
have puppies and to have things around
in our life and they're living on
another side we really also work heavily
as a wildlife conservation education
organization we have we have our own
camps in the deep jungles of Sumatra but
we hire the Rangers for we've built the
stations we have guys out every day
picking up stairs chasing poachers we
deliver drones around the world to anti
poaching teams of fly drones and find
poachers we've put millions of dollars
into programs like this those characters
have never even considered doing things
like now it's completely outside of what
they're up to
we're on a different side that is the
American Zoo Association the City zoos
they're running a program where
everybody's equal and everybody can care
for it no one there needs to have their
hands on a tiger so they say puts their
hands on a tiger is wrong and they need
to be right more people go the zoos in
America then all professional sports
events combined we realize there's
billions of dollars at stake in zoo
visitation and if I didn't realize that
at all
it's huge the big zoos are raking in
phenomena money San Diego Zoo
keeps keeps money in reserve of over
half a billion dollars just to keep
things running their overhead is
hundreds of millions of dollars and it's
from the public pouring money into it
because most of the public loves
wildlife and wants to see it from afar
they really wish they could hold it but
most of them don't even realize it's
possible to do it securely and
beneficially somewhere doing it here
creates a big multi-sided benefit where
you get to see the animals and paid for
their wild project restoration so that
they have a place to live hopefully the
Kingsmen forward as we all make up our
mind whether we're gonna hold the world
for wildlife or if we're gonna hold the
road for these people we've gotta come
up with a decision there for the wild
world be left alone a little bit
everybody wants their slice of it
already was that piece valuable asset
you know everything's an asset good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one